you know the Johnny Depp Amber Heard
thing was a great example of in a
gunfight between those two everyone was
cheering for the bullets I mean no one
was I don't think anybody looked like a
hero they both looked like what they are
which is humans really flawed humans who
had
you know it really is like that that
People magazine thing Stars they're just
like us you know like we watched that
and went like oh yeah they're just like
us like they cannot keep it together
they cannot have like they just have
these ridiculous toxic moments where
both of them look awful in that trial
well what do you take away from that
trial just it just given given all the
work you've done I mean for me I don't
know if you could speak to that it's
probably the first time I've seen
that kind of
a complicated relationship even just to
say a relationship laid out in this raw
form like the fights of a relationship
yeah my feeling about that trial is
there is no amount of money that would
be worth laying that kind of stuff bare
publicly for you if you were dying to me
yeah there's no way I don't know because
they both look awful they both look
awful and I don't think I I don't think
I'm qualified to say if one of or both
of them are awful
but they both had moments in that
courtroom where their behavior and words
looked awful
and and I just don't know that that
exposing that to the world like the I
just don't know I mean I understand the
point of view that that by bringing that
suit Johnny Depp was saying look I yeah
I have to show these awful things to the
world about myself but it's it's not as
bad as what she's claimed I've done so I
get it I'm not saying that's incorrect
and for Amber Heard I think her response
is well for him to say I'm lying you
know I have to prove my but my God like
what an awful thing to watch I I it was
all it really is is just another it's
just another couple like well there's so
you know how banal that is you know many
kind of stuff happens a lot a lot it's
the norm it's not it's not the exception
they just happen to have like a grand
scale because they have you know lots of
people around them and lots of money but
yeah it's all this that kind of
dysfunction that kind of chaos that kind
of he said she said two people with
completely differing histories of what
happened in the marriage false
allegations of domestic violence or true
allegations of domestic violence that
are completely denied by the person and
you have witnesses that will say oh my
God they never engaged in any kind
because again no one engages in domestic
violence with company over you know you
don't like invite friends like people
always say like oh no I saw them they
seem so happy like people always do this
to me as a divorce lawyer they come in
and they go well here's photos of the
kids you know smiling with me so that's
proof that like I'm a good dad I'm like
there's photos of Jeffrey Dahmer smiling
with people he ate later and you're you
think these photos prove something like
I I don't the lack of I'm in the middle
of a very complex domestic violence
trial and the entire defense on the
other side is well we have photos of
them on vacation where they look very
happy and she never called the cops
that's no defense at all like most
victims of intimate partner abuse don't
call the cops they don't identify
self-identify as victims of domestic
violence and they probably have many
stretches of time of intense happiness
or happiness of course and by the way
perpetrators of domestic violence are
charismatic
how else would they get victims you know
it's not like if they were ogrish no one
would sign on for that relationship it's
that when they're good they're so good
that when they're bad you go but wait no
that's not him the really good person is
him or her you know we saw that in in in
the public testimony of that you know
deaf herd thing is there were moments
where you look at her and go oh my God
like I want one just like that and there
are moments where you listen to the
testimony and go oh my God she's awful
like what that's just evil yeah and the
same for him so I I really
this should teach us something about
how not only are there two sides to
every story like that that there's just
so much complexity and Nuance to these
but I think it
everyone was asking the question whether
you were team depth team heard or team I
could care less about either of these
people
everybody's looking at it going why like
why eight billion people in the world
why did you stay together just break up
you're miserable it's obvious it's
obvious you're not this this can't be
worth it I've uh actually become
friendly with Kamil Vasquez who's uh the
lawyer on the depth side she's an
incredible woman great lawyer and just a
great human being just how passionate
she's about to work I mean you you
radiate this kind of same passion like
she's just truly happy doing what she
does yeah and and but also
where the stress of a case
is like takes like it is Becomes Her
She's you can't sleep all this kind of
stuff which is fascinating that's I
think that's a function of our
professions we we
um even after 20 plus years of doing
this like the night before a trial I can
hardly sleep and I excitement fear yes
yes okay all of that all of that and and
I even have moments as I I I pull up to
the courthouse and I listen I wear
certain cuff links that are like my
lucky cuff links or something and and I
pull up to the courthouse I walk into
the courtroom and I have this feeling in
the pit of my stomach and then it starts
and the moment it starts something in me
goes oh yeah I know how to do this yeah
and it's instantly like I just I own it
I love it and it's yeah it's the the
people that love this job you know being
a a trial lawyer being a particularly a
divorce trial lawyer family law trial
lawyer it's I love it I love I I love it
more than I loved it when I started
doing it I still you know I I can't
imagine spending five days a week
looking forward to two you know I I love
what I do I I don't know that I'll ever
love anyone or anything more than I love
the work